[Music]
gilina had the look of love on
Valentine's Day you got a fetish for my
check out Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber
stepping out for an intimate date night
on February 14th first the couple was
spotted walking into church for midweek
service justin kept things casual in a
jean jacket and khaki pants while Selena
dressed up in a sheep plaid blazer black
dress and patent leather flats after
service they were seen heading to one of
their favorite spots the montage hotel
for a romantic dinner for two
an eyewitness spot at the lovebirds
packing on the PDA while enjoying their
late dinner it's nice to see Jelena
making things work a source told et they
are handling their relationship
differently this time around quote
they've both matured and have very
different priorities
adding Justin isn't interested in
partying and Selena is much more
confident and isn't afraid to put her
needs ahead of anyone elses I'm
constantly somebody that likes to grow
and feel like alright what could I be
better at what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger and and then I'm 25 so I feel
like I'm gonna change a lot
[Music]